[Música]
Bueno ya llega el espacio el espacio
económico aquí a directo América edición
nocturna Para ello nos acompaña hoy de
nuevo nuestra compañera Daniela Blandón
Daniela bienvenida Gracias y vamos a
empezar en Estados Unidos donde no hubo
sorpresas en esa reunión por el intento
de agrandar el techo de la deuda pues
esto era lo que se esperaba básicamente
los republicanos están manteniendo en su
posición de que aceptan subir ese límite
desde los actuales 31,4 billones de
dólares en 1,5 billones pero con la
condición de reducir drásticamente el
gasto público eso incluiría quitar
recursos a proyectos clave de biden como
la condonación de deudas a estudiantes
también la entrega de subsidios para la
industria que migre hacia las energías
limpias
No vi ningún movimiento nuevo el
presidente dijo que el personal debía
volver a reunirse pero fui muy claro con
el presidente Ahora solo nos quedan dos
semanas Si Chuck Summer pudiera probar
algo iríamos a conferencia enseguida y
lo resolveríamos pero no creo que pueda
probar nada no lo ha tratado
desafortunadamente el presidente ha
esperado 97 días sin reunirse
lo que es realmente preocupante en la
posición del presidente de la cámara es
que tiene un proyecto de ley totalmente
partidista y él dice tómenla o déjela o
podemos caer en default al no quitar el
default de sobre la mesa El Señor
mccarthy está poniendo Estados Unidos en
grave peligro y haciendo que sea mucho
más difícil avanzar en las negociaciones
sobre el presupuesto
ahí teníamos entonces las dos posiciones
de todas maneras la Casa Blanca
considera la actitud de los republicanos
como un chantaje y asegura que esto no
debería estarse negociando el presidente
inclusive dijo estar dispuesto a
considerar invocar la décimo cuarta
enmienda de la Constitución de Estados
Unidos esto para subir ese tope sin la
aprobación del Congreso pero todo esto
diría hasta los tribunales y se
complicaría todavía más bueno Daniela
pero estamos seguros de que antes de
llegar a eso acabarán llegando a un
acuerdo in extremis Como sucede
normalmente Como sucede todos los años
porque esta es una discusión que se
aprobándolo en último minuto claro bueno
entre tanto como han respondido Las
bolsas a esta noticia pues Wall Street
desarrolló en rojo con los nervios de
punta por lo que pueda pasar con esta
deuda Y es que si no hay un acuerdo de
Estados Unidos caería en el primer
impago de su historia un escenario que
dejaría sin ingresos a empleados
federales a militares y pensionados las
bolsas europeas cerraron mixtas con los
ojos puestos sobre esta misma
negociación también comienzan a
barajarse los peores escenarios para el
resto del mundo porque Estados Unidos es
la economía más importante y muchos de
los mercados dependen del comportamiento
de su economía y también de sus bonos
que son los papeles que emite para
financiarse de hecho ya se está viendo
como los inversionistas se deshacen de
esos papeles y lo que hace es que el
precio baje en América Latina la bolsa
de México encadenó tres sesiones en
positivo y hoy reveló que su inflación
interanual en abril fue del 6,5%, su
menor nivel desde octubre de 2021
pues Daniela nos hablabas de bolsas
europeas vamos a ir ahora también a
Europa Porque extenderá los beneficios
la Unión Europea los beneficios
tributarios a la entrada de productos
ucranianos Pues el pleno del parlamento
europeo respaldó mantener por otro año
más la suspensión de los derechos de
importación de los productos agrícolas
de Ucrania esto para seguirla apoyando
mientras se defiende de Rusia en
concreto la suspensión de aranceles se
aplicaría las frutas a las hortalizas y
también a otros productos agrícolas
porque ya los industriales estaban
sujetos de arancel cero desde el pasado
primero de enero en un virtud en virtud
de un acuerdo al que habían llegado con
la Unión Europea eso no está incluido
dentro de la nueva propuesta de todas
maneras le hace falta una instancia
final que es la comisión europea sin
embargo como lo hemos dicho varias veces
Acá hay países que unilateralmente han
decidido cerrar sus puertas a esas
importaciones sin aranceles de Ucrania
porque están afectando a sus productores
en la medida que les llega producto más
barato al respecto habló el presidente
bolo de Mercedes
todas las restricciones a nuestras
exportaciones son completamente
inaceptables en este momento porque no
nos refuerzan a todos en Europa sino que
sólo refuerzan a las habilidades del
agresor y Daniela vamos a cerrar con la
cifra del día 62,6 millones de euros
esta fue la inversión del grupo francés
carrefour en sus primeras 50 sucursales
en Israel se trata del primer
distribuidor extranjero en instalarse en
este país con su primera tienda en tel
aviv considerada una de las ciudades más
costosas del mundo esa empresa llega con
la promesa de bajar los precios en
particular de los alimentos en una
nación que hoy tiene la inflación más
alta en una década ahora se espera para
finales de este año que la cadena tenga
entre 80 y 100 sucursales esperemos si
les va bien allá en Israel Muchas
gracias Daniela por este repaso
económico vamos ya con directo a